can you turn the music off yeah yeah
okay we're live
i'll roll first
so joe how do you like the awesome
comedy scene
it's been a month down here
wow where are you from connecticut
yesterday
six
um
so do you guys do the snake draft thing
where it's like yeah if you pick last
twice it goes back around well that's
how you play katan
i don't know
i'm a 10
youtuber since this is 8.5
4.
it's a great scene i mean there's so
much pokemon there's so much hope and
optimism here it's crazy
11 [ __ ] night
you go first
actually there is a dude hey
i've been very happy with the decision i
was gonna move to new york and then i
came down here for halloween just to
make sure i wasn't making a mistake
and i like came down here i had a
[ __ ] blast and i signed a lease and
so yeah and then i came back down you
did open mike's in uh october i did a
few shows while i was down here yeah i
didn't get to play the creek or anything
but i did a
couple book shows they were in
connecticut the whole time yes sir
is there a good comedy scene there
there's not no there's a 12 right here i
miss that there's um
there's not i don't know it's obviously
pretty shitty uh there's some great
comics but to be honest like i started
in boston i was out of san francisco i
was just kind of home during the
pandemic hanging out
yeah that's what i did too were you
during the pandemic i was doing a road
trip to miami
and then the pandemic hit right when i
hit miami
and so i traveled all the way from miami
to seattle in a van
living in it and then i went from
seattle to l.a i tried quarantine for
like
six months and then from la i
quarantined in the desert just camped
for like four months and then i came
here and i've been here 10 months
how was that in the pandora
it was weird yeah
everyone was like it was like we were
doing something naughty
but you get away with it you get any you
get any shows like you were able to get
up a good bit or what yeah there was a
lot of open mics there's always grungy
shitty comics willing to sacrifice their
body
100
common theme stand up
yeah i mean it was a good scene it was
there were a lot of funny people there
oh sweet
let's see this it's a nice it's my
second choice right there
so how long you guys been doing this
thing
this year you said you played your first
game earlier yeah yeah you're playing
your first game right now mm-hmm and how
many have you been in it have you played
this before i'm an expert okay there we
go so we got
we got three
all right we got three season bets and a
couple rookies but maybe you never know
they're ai players that's what i call
these are the same
ai player
all right so
where can i go
any vertex
so any three section intersection right
sides
let's roll
you get five a little bit this says ten
millimeters all right when an eight's
rolled you get a reason that's eleven
dots so this is good it takes that's
gonna say because i rolled a six
i'm a little high and very chatty here
look at that so that's what you need to
build everything
dude is this pizza going
you should call them
i think
did you order any cinna sticks
no or cheese right now why don't you
take those oh
i'm gonna call it to make sure you guys
are okay
yeah just be super rude to the people
making our food no not rich i want to go
yeah it's annoying and
i work in food business and i ordered it
like over an hour ago dude what time is
it
go what time did it go through
at um
8 54.
what could have happened to is they
dropped off at the wrong house so some
one of our neighbors probably got a free
pizza
that would be the worst no it could be
the super bowl saw
i should
i should call the [ __ ] fed but you know
you know as long as you're enjoying
yourself at least i know where the where
the store is you know yeah and i'll be
right back you want to go drive over
there and see all of those
legs
all right
where are we going
can i do that see what that's a [ __ ]
great idea because
if you'll never know you'll never
disappointed having a little extra wheat
dude
wheat holds it down are you gonna wheat
could you hand me my wheat pin over
there your weed pan
the live wheat where is it
yeah
they have so much energy
okay one of these open space right here
oh perfect that's just not bench
snowman's land i mean okay why
yeah cause i could take comedy today
very high testosterone and i just got
off stage so i'm feeling that freaking
call yourself yeah dude that's such a
weird thing to tell yourself it feels
great you crouch dude i do too but just
like you went up in fact yes yeah yeah
that was fun i did dean samuel showed
the creep then it was fun okay he always
has a good crowd over there dean's the
man love dean
did my podcast over the weekend it's fun
he brought me venison
nobody's ever done that
from a tribe
yeah it's interesting because like
you're annoying
it's me
yes
why am i annoying hans because you're
like oh look the i didn't get to do the
little coal camp little golden ratio
little pattern that i usually do if you
got something
ratio don't worry about it you were just
moving some numbers around i was like
maybe maybe you wanted to yeah maybe
like adapt to a new situation
i'm adapted you're adapting very loudly
we're getting into it
he's from the northeast
i am i'm from the northeast
that's true
so now it's
the next person's turn
okay oh it is me no no it was so when
you're done like let people know you're
oh yeah so it's oh so we're going in
order of the numbers
we're not going in the order of the
numbers all right
you got to give me
it's a little circle started with you
then it went to me then i went to dallas
got it got it okay
we're figuring it out guys one one step
at a time we're getting there we're
gonna find a rhythm we're gonna [ __ ]
figure out a rhythm i think hans is just
intimidated by my katan prowess and i
think he knows that i came prepared yeah
that's right what i'm concerned about is
the katan
not just your general essence as a human
hans that's not very nice i know
i know hans this is my first that's why
i was trying to be like hey it's like uh
you know like
the katana is really secondary
fair enough
yeah
is it katana or katan
um
so uh what do you think about uh the joe
rogan controversy
i don't know what i think about it i
just smoked weed for the first time in a
month hans is yelling at me about
numbers i'm a little thrown off so oh
you're doing great it's not what i
expected to get into i was
this is not the warm welcoming katan but
i'm too much with the numbers evidently
so we're figuring it out well we all
find our limits and then we push it so
like whatever like
whatever people will let us get away
with that's what we'll do 100 have you
found that people have been letting you
get away with more or less lately than
you were getting away with
i think that i've been
doing a good job of uh just maintaining
my ego and yelling at the people that
deserve it
fair enough
i go yeah so what are we live streaming
on here are we on why don't you let
someone else talk okay
worldwide jesus christ hans
it's just weird like
it's always you know
no but uh yeah you're like really
with like uh
uh you know like you have a strong frame
as they say in the pickup artist
community
are you a pickup artist yeah nice that's
sick
who's jersey i who it is caleb's turn oh
yeah oh it's my turn yeah okay because
it snakes back okay yeah
um
yeah where's the dice
no you just place the settlement place
the second one that's right yeah um
he's one of the new ones yeah uh caleb
and dallas right now why didn't you guys
set your two down then
caleb and dallas are new uh kareem and
joe are veterans
i'm a veteran 20 45 years
45
so kareem you work in the health care
industry uh how are the ups and downs
it's fine
work his work
oracle said you freaking know the name
of that it's andrew dice clay dude
that's the name of the thing
this that's the introduction
what are you doing with that spot that's
the cup
you can't do it wait hans all right it's
illegal that's right you're not
explaining the rules
you're gonna be two away
so you can't pick a spot
and you can pick anywhere on the board
they're gonna pick clothes
yeah you got to think of uh like what
elements you're not like what you need
rocky and you're going to write all the
elements at some point yeah
really yeah
what's
i'm going fun turn 11
i'm over there
i need rock and i need wood
eight
i think i was stuck
there
yeah so the second thing you put down
here you take a card for everything that
you touch in
it's a wood rock and shape
okay
and wheat
so uh i got a new dice cup
this works leslie
you put it down
pick it up
now
there's the number
it's pretty legit when you put it on
you're right for that
you have to shake the dice up now
no
you can just
you can just start rolling in the cup
where did you don't see the
demonstration i would
there we go we got an eight
night
all right
i'm gonna pass
nice you almost shut it
that's it we figured it out
uh okay yeah sorry
what kind of jersey are you from again
uh it's called stanhope it's like north
jersey it's called you buy anything
the stress factor don't you have to sign
up on the email to go on their own like
i never wanted to build different ways
to set one of these things on board
they have one in new brunswick i was
there
i did some comic shop show that new
brunswick
nine
damn dude i'm not getting the [ __ ]
anything
nine orange you get a sheep
yo
good sheep coming in
pick up a sheet all right
yeah so every time they roll the number
there we go we'll take one of the cards
seven something oh all right where's
that number at we know again
all right yeah i think um
[Music]
sorry hans
thank you buddy
hey does anybody want to trade a wood
for a wheat i got a wood and i would
like oak wheat oh well i'll give you a
wood bro if you gotta wait
for oh oh i think okay so
i'll give you a wood big boy
anybody need uh
anybody got wheat they'd like to part
with for a little wood if not i'm moving
on i believe
all right moving on han's all you buddy
thanks joe yes sir
you're welcome oh [ __ ]
seven it's funny dude it hits you [ __ ] i
wonder who it's coming after
good idea
both of you sorry dallas your collateral
damage
the tides have turned
appreciated who wants wood
um i got something i'll give you free
wood brick
another wood
what about
wood for wood straight up to wood
for one wood honestly i don't need it
if you don't need wood
that's fine
okay this is a very wooded game
a lot of wood plenty of wood to go
around
okay
what's in this shape
the couch for the brown couch boys all
you guys are in here yeah
that's awesome you want to join us
i think only if i can sleep in your room
dude
dude you're a rich tech boy you don't
need
to live here
all right
yes i am that's correct
don't be too proud of it
people said you guys live here the sheep
appreciate the enthusiasm though
we're going to need that
so
i think the dominoes is owned by jewish
people
sex
sex i think it's owned by koreans
technically
the best racer
these korean people are the worst
wait and they said yeah we said a lot of
you like three young kids in my high
school thanks very much
a lot of kids are left a lot of leaves
there are a lot of leaves as well dude
these are actually so it's like that sex
does anyone have a sex i died yeah i got
a little wheat going dude the more
koreans the better i say wow
does anyone have sheep for wood no
mm-hmm my grandfather fought me in the
middle wow
that was a good one
a lot of dead
koreans in that one
to be honest it's kind of embarrassing
but i could not tell you a [ __ ] thing
about the korean war all my grandfather
would say it was cold and so some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] definitely that's sad
that like that's literally what that
means
by the way sonny if you have more than
eight cards
you got to get rid of half
so how cool next turn you might want to
spend them that's what i was going to do
anybody want to anybody got a wheat they
want to give me for this wood i'm
guessing the answers are hard no all
right what went on
nice
i like a man with pandash
i'm not gonna lie i don't know what that
word means but that's okay ten
yes
all right we got our first three-pointer
on the board
gotta change the uh scoresheet
uh roll first or can i already do like a
development yeah you gotta roll first oh
you can do it yeah
yeah do a development card no you can
use it but you can't buy music
you can use a development card but you
can't buy a development card no oh yeah
okay so you rolled it
right
oh
another four
four's galore
you buy it can i use this to get a
development yeah
throw it down baby
so does anybody come through here and
just surprise you with their katan
prowess anybody really this guy's going
to [ __ ] stink and just lit it up out
here yeah
kareem are you looking at me everyone's
won before
it's a very fair game
i know it's funny there's really nobody
no it's really about networking and
trying to get on shows
it is yeah that's true oh i'm aware i'm
after eight years i'm aware of that
where'd you start stand up
dallas i was sick man
and then uh i moved
back here i'm from here at the original
from austin originally that's what's up
there you're done is it weird to see the
[ __ ] city change and everything no
it's very normal actually really yeah
yeah some people hate it some people
don't care if you're on board with it
uh you know it's a love hate thing
whatever wherever you're from you know
it's it's all the same so amen that was
seven seasons [ __ ] yeah
uh [ __ ] who's winning right now
right yeah i think it's on but yeah
that's always
yeah i might uh
come on over well actually let's see
he's got that i don't got it
let's see here
i have i don't have that
so i might come over here
and uh
uh what do you got hans
we got
i will not forget this
uh do you have any bricks nope you don't
know yes you just go grab it right okay
yeah it's just one right yeah yeah yeah
okay
or are you all done now
okay
uh
all right i might let's see
so who are some of your favorites on the
scene casey rocket
oh dude heather shaw is [ __ ]
hilarious i'm a fan for sure did she do
open mics
see her bouncing around she's i see her
on
tick tock and she's kicked it very nice
to me showed up so i appreciate that
where are you oh yeah
she's from florida
this is what i was originally nice
yes for you heather shaw won one of our
one-liner competition shows oh is that
you guys you're in the one-liner company
yeah it's me raymond cabrera and james
torres okay it worked yeah i dropped by
there with dean
um
on saturday after the pod but yeah we
got another one today
so hell yeah [ __ ]
are you more of a one-liner guy
i'm gonna go ahead and i'm gonna build a
little city
what's that
what the am i on it
oh you're on the uh there you go
24th you're on thursday at the new buzz
mill the seventh street one so that's
right over by where i live i've i've
been having a [ __ ] wicked good time i
can't beat the two shows on that at that
place nice i feel lucky i can like
technically do it i don't know living in
i lived in a town called sunnyvale and
you had to drive to get everywhere which
is kind of a pain in the ass and i'm
walking distance to both the clubs and
like a lot of mike so that's [ __ ]
nice nice
yeah yeah i want to do comedy there at
some point yeah hit me up if you go out
there i'll help y'all for sure really
nine
you got a sheep did you pick up a sheep
i'm getting a lot of sheep over here
do you want to trade i'll give you a
wood for one of those sheep after your
goal
wait did you roll yet no no
10
what was it 10.
four
fours are hot right now and
oh [ __ ] we forgot to make that deal
too late now
yeah yeah yeah
wait 100
nice shoots
nine she wear there
all right does anyone have any wheat for
what
you you're giving wood or you're
receiving it
i'm giving wood i'm gonna think i'm
giving a lot of wood for it i got dude i
i could maybe have a week cuz i'll give
you a lot of wood for it dude i'm sorry
i can't help you out in that department
yeah two wood for wheat three wood per
week
no all right i'll go [ __ ] myself
thank you
okay don't got weak
six
okay
we got a little wheat coming in
oh there you go there it is all right
well
um crazy right now
i'm gonna go ahead i'm gonna take all
the cards
okay
moving
on on scam all you baby thanks joe
begley of course
so it how is the tech talk going
[ __ ] is pivoted i've i've pretty much
stopped using the tick tock and i've
been using the instagram reels nice it's
been going pretty well lately is it a
positive community
um a lot of people are dicks and don't
like me very much and
but
dude with the negative comments you just
i just try to find something like stupid
to say back to them really people are
[ __ ] horrible yeah yeah yeah anything
maybe you post you're always gonna no
one should [ __ ] like dude
people are always gonna say mean people
come people come at the head right off
the bat
i'm pretty happy about that that's
awesome yeah
have you always been like sort of like
the attention seek grabbing person and
pretty much high school by the way um
this game has gone so far i think that's
exactly the type of dude that i am you
like jackass
um i can't skateboard i was never a good
skater so jackass is not a good fit for
your boy
everybody want sheep
you want a wood for that sheep oh dude
i'll give you some you [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of these shades i'll give you two
sheeps oh [ __ ] i'm like god
do whatever the [ __ ] you want with her
she damn see if i win hans is gonna come
back later and be like never a duty
that's a good point
got two sheep here i'm only taking one
don't don't do that to yourself don't
give yourself a fighting chance i got
all wooden sheep
maybe like
equally four wooden four sheep
well you can oh you can trade four for
one resource at any rate any time
eventually
we're all just we're giving them yes we
gotta need like one of those cards
or one of those down to get that one
card you need just to get the white card
i don't know i don't even think i could
make anything
yeah got a lot of wood and cheap
so how long have you been down here in
austin you can uh
[Music]
yeah
do anything i've been here like 10
months your fan
yeah seems to be working out yeah if i
hate it who would love it
everything's going great
all right
rogan is cool are you done
tony hinchcliffe is cool
it's a pretty cool time
forgive you
um does anybody have a brick yeah she i
have ore
huh i have ore
i got four one of these these things oh
rotten yeah
i got a rock dude or okay whatever you
want to call it rock harvey you wouldn't
give me that for what i'll give you for
two woods for two woods yeah
you'll get double pounded i'm done let's
go yeah let's do it here
all right cool
oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean yeah the ranch starting only fan
for you
i mean
the money they're making i'm down for it
ten ten
does anyone have a weight
i have a sheep
no
i have a [ __ ] a lot of cards i'm
praying there's no sevens coming up
you gotta hold it down
it's all all new because you're the last
person who rolls for uh
wait
what uh whatever did you rub on
yeah i'm getting shaped as well
all right
savvy [ __ ] me god dammit
that would suck
wood sucked sucks beating me dude
all right i'm gonna
go wood
couple [ __ ]
what shows are you guys doing
do you really know what am i watching uh
60 days in it's awesome john netflix 60
days and about the civilians that are
here
it's a it's not simply courtney that's
running that show isn't it i think it is
oh he is okay yeah i haven't been back
here in a while
really
i'm doing dan p's show tomorrow and then
i'm doing the nasty show on saturday
seven
[ __ ] me dude
i've got seven on the dodge
fire away big guy
oops
looking like sheep and double seven oh i
i'm the sheep guy
are you done with yours no no no no it's
sheep or wood right
i'm good i'm not
i'm good
i get using more sheep though
sick thanks let's [ __ ] go
sheep
[Music]
uh
i mean there's always more sheep
good turn [ __ ] um
that's too much wood right there for
this game
um 11
11
yeah perfect that's what we needed
um
actually
let's go
not have you
for what no didn't think so
do you have sheep though sex not anymore
no longer
okay um does anybody
yes want to trade me a brick you got
that brick what do you want for it
you have a let's see do you got a rock i
do
i'll give you the rock okay let's do it
rock yeah i'm gonna play this road
building card
and i'm gonna meander me way over here
and then i'm gonna throw down
that was that then this
boom
we got another settlement going
moving on
six
nice
do you want bricks dallas
oh yeah i got wood for you baby what
about wheat
uh
i need to wait or at least i can give
you one
one
that's um
hold on
five
all right
what do i do with this
please hold on sign it oh yeah
until you win
hey
how are you bastards that covered spot
big blocking
they're blocking your chin
nine no dude that nine's been hot
tonight
oh my bad bro
that's what i'm talking about oh but
it goes
all right you're good
hey again [ __ ] dude who covered us up
over there every time tons son of a
[ __ ] sorry guys son of a [ __ ] does
anybody want to uh that's that's tony
that's how tony said does anybody want
to trade me a little a little brick or a
little war
anybody got war to give but what no no
what do you uh what do you want
more wheat
okay
do that thank you
it's very nice dice cup you got there
it's new it's first time we're using it
seven
sh
ooh yeah
the [ __ ]
um
feeling pretty good about it
feel good
so was it the spider in the hot span
we were teaching this guy so
i was in my rookie season
you couldn't talk about how quiet it is
because then it makes us self-conscious
it's the last way i want your feelings
yeah you just ruin moments
enjoy that wood thanks
[Music]
well i do want to put it
this is cool
[Music]
so you got to build a road first in
order to
to build that what's going on over here
with this no no no oh yeah so you got to
be like two two roads away from wherever
you're at
yeah and you couldn't build there so you
might want to start building something
over there or down to there i have no
cards
so you can get back the sheep and the
wheat and then build a road yeah exactly
just build your road for now
yeah
yeah you can lay down what are you doing
i'm downtown actually i'm on west fifth
okay oh yeah i just got here like a
couple months ago nice man how you
liking it that's [ __ ] dealt dude it's
been it's a good time
yes
what the [ __ ]
that was a six year old right yep yeah
we don't got time
12. whoa
oh [ __ ]
there we go that's all you do
one wood
to get one
wood you got twelve
don't you have two
do what whatever where where where there
you go right there [ __ ] dude
and you caleb what
yeah i already got it oh no
seven
all right
we all good
hands i'm sorry buddy
anybody want to
excuse me all right anybody want to
trade uh i've got an ore here anybody
want to give me a wood yeah for that all
right done
i'll build a little uh
a little road down yonder
all right that's all i got man
i got more weapon forest dog let's do
this
you would see me i know where that's
going
hit the 34
all right
i forgive him
well it goes both ways he's picking on
me you're doing well and so am i so it's
a it's a it's a fair trade off here
honestly i hope everybody wins
show up in california
yeah you're right
where were you in cali san diego oh sick
you doing stand up out there yeah a
little bit america so many club mad
house bikes
nice la jolla comedy store i never once
i never did the store that mike was
crazy he had a call on a wednesday to
try and like sign up and it was like
yeah what time you had to call it like
three o'clock
to get
on it like six or seven it was three
minutes so like i never got a pros
but that house was chilly you put in
what dates you're available and they'll
just like sign up for the whole week if
you want
11.
i think my time in new york though when
i was you know was the best dude for
sure
were you there during the pandemic
no i mean before pandemic yeah i was
doing gotham in like 2016-17
oh jared seinfeld showed up to like
couple new talent shows i did that was
this was a gaffing show that i was like
oh
and then i was like oh you know seven
they would just they would go to gotham
so i would just happen to be there too
that sucks
until i would um
i [ __ ] up again at gotham
did you yeah yeah he's so good dude yeah
he's great he fist bumped me once
because i was
i was like he's about to go on and i set
him up and he was like
yeah i feel like new york is really good
for comedy
yeah like it makes you better so much
faster oh i mean i'm [ __ ] this room
too awesome
yeah it's just everyone from around the
world you know yeah those audiences are
so good i love i fed off that like
gotham 300 people and i was like what
like i have that's where i get all my
tapes dude tape them too because they're
brand new shows
and i bring like 15 to 20 people did you
bring hers of gotham oh wait yeah
that you bro you wrote a whole book
about starting that club after it was
the improv
sheba yeah there was a woman
oh no it's like you're going to the
daughter but there's this other guy who
does the uh gotham shows are you done
kayla okay um no i i'm i'm trying to
exactly
said my role because of you it was a
nice ask so i might come here afterwards
okay yeah sorry i might draw yeah
i need to add them
did you go to the grizzly pair
no i never did that that one is so
ratchet yeah it's like the ratchet
seller you're ready after the comedy's
over and they turned into a bar
yeah yeah
i did a guest spot at the broadway
comedy club once it was
it was all right
i mean yeah okay
it's a tourist trap you gotta shoot yeah
damn i didn't know hollywood i used to
be like that guy bud friedman used to be
they went out of sheep for a week
excuse me
you got [ __ ]
got [ __ ] sheep
she poor dog whatever you want with it
i eat it
i get a seven i'm not going to their mom
i want a peace treaty here too much
too much war in these trying times i
know
we should be getting along
so frustrating it really is
h
resources
um
how long has katan been around by the
way when was it made eighteen ninety
three
the lms sales from the great 1893
classic game yeah yeah edison just play
it
you'd be super into it damn
way to go edison
yeah monopoly is still popular
somehow
by the way we have mario monopoly up
there oh
i'm big into monopoly dude
yeah during the pandemic we got big into
katana monopoly was a good time
all right [ __ ] hey
nine another one yeah
does anybody want to trade a
let's see i'll give you a brick for a
sheep
does she i don't have any sheet on
not quite yet
um
trying to get a knight so i can liberate
myself from this
tyranny yeah i'll give you um
a wood for a rock
or i can't do it actually
you know what yeah let's do a [ __ ]
look at that oh yeah
should we help me
well cool
what's the best open mic in austin what
do you think it is what's your what's
your pick probably buzz mill or the
creek
sunday creek is [ __ ] awesome
that heckle mike is double [ __ ] yeah i
like that [ __ ]
oh i heard that's fun
lucky duck used to be the best
it still is good it's still not yeah it
can be good
questions
or i do ever would it's the luggage
sheep
no i know yeah or i'll do it for a week
i can't do it
right really the leg of the draw
or you'll do or for a week
yeah all right let's do it
all right
oh my god we're trapping boys trapping
oh [ __ ]
should make a drug dealer version of
this game
straight up yeah
all right you're good all right let's do
it
like i'll take your meth for your crack
yeah
sorry i name drop something
i don't know if i'm supposed to take
that
all right um anybody want to go or i got
or i would love a wheat if you got one
don't trade with him he's winning yes
all i'll embargo myself on that one
so i gotta i gotta subs
whatever
who wants wood
i need rock sheep yeah you're shaving to
the 10th degree
no one wants wheat or sheep
uh do you have a rock no i need a rock
i do too
oh [ __ ]
does that mean i get the pellet someone
moved that bus yeah
i don't know who that is
okay that's kareem and kya caleb yeah so
both of us dude this pizza is not coming
what oh no dude i knew uh people and i
called him
damn are you serious do i get the church
on his attitude
it was like two hours ago bro it's a
sign wait why didn't you just take from
this [ __ ] did you take your memory
uh-huh yeah oh no that's it you only
take one of us oh okay yeah oh i see
yeah
damn
so
[Music]
yeah i love buzz mill i love the creek
plus most [ __ ] great
yeah i like the dude andre that runs it
he crushes every time i've seen him and
yeah he's [ __ ] awesome he's got that
cool
calm collected energy yeah i'm envious
to that
you got the high
attentive
you know always their energy i've never
been described as attentive before so i
appreciate that does anybody want to
wheat
attention deficit disorder oh yeah you
got to fire it on rock blinders yeah
yeah does that have any wrong way
you don't want to weep
you're sure
it's whole grain
okay
and
[ __ ]
stuck in the sand together everything we
played
for those [ __ ]
man
force
not to be mistaken like porous
ultra horses
three wood
okay i'll do three wood
what are you giving away um
actually
does anyone have any break
what do you what are you gonna wait for
that does it do you have a break maybe
what are you good i have wheat or
i
yeah yeah
see man i give everybody good price oh
yeah i give everybody a good price whoa
whoa i didn't say it like that everybody
my friends
that's how i said it
okay
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
i have eight [ __ ] okay
one two
redisposing these
dude
what is it none of us can get it on the
right pile
never proposed a peace treaty but
every night
let's go
seven
where could he be going with this one
right back to you dudes same one
anyone want brick
yeah for what rock gotcha no i don't
have that
i have a wood or a weave
you son of a [ __ ]
can't take another develop card
yeah unless you can
we got to pay the bank for it though
gotta pay the troll
take it in
sounds like you're saying boy what no
that was soul
i'm trying to
are you done yeah i'm dead
to think that that show helped danny
devito out so much
think it's the other way around i mean
that shows nothing without them
true they helped each other out equally
because he didn't come in until what the
second season or was it second yeah
second season like the second episode of
the second season it's imagine if you're
them and danny it was like i wanted i
should like no they saw him
oh really yeah i just that's wild to me
does anybody want any wheat or wood for
uh or
i'll change some word for some week you
want some i'm gonna have a hundred oh
wait uh
do you know how many or nobody's gotta
work
hans you you don't wanna give up your
ore
so what is on streaming this [ __ ] on
i have no idea i think it's on grindr
live or something oh grinder yeah i
think i'm familiar that's a good yeah
that's a really affordable dude
are they chirping in they're definitely
saying am i getting some [ __ ] yeah
somebody says mega
they must really love the wood on this
nice that's good
you know i'm bragging about all my
[ __ ] sheep that i'm sure
i mean
you do whatever you want with them
literally that was part of the deal
i'm not gonna judge
it's all business on your side
[Music]
oh that's so funny seven
wait till you see it
[Music]
all right i'll put this here i'm gonna
take from what's your role i rolled
seven
you got a dump
you got eight there
nine actually
ten sorry eleven
i'll take from you
then i'd also like to relinquish my
other night card oh
and go back to you
so you have attitude whichever one you'd
like appreciate you bro goodbyes
what a palestinian thief
appreciate both you guys
does anyone have any sheep for what
[ __ ] oh wait those scots dude
just fast
that's how they got their curly hair
i'm gonna grab road for longest
right you
ass uh where is that
um
does anyone have any break for an oar
or what
um we want some already some wait for
work
oh what do you mean what else
we said do you have any prey
i don't know right really i'm not
dude i'm just being bum-fucked right now
you don't want to be another brick
involved
all right let's do it
[ __ ] you know that
there you go
seven
move that
bus i got seven
conquerors
oh yeah please
primetime abc tv i haven't finally been
seen
sex not i wasn't addicted to that with
my family back in the day yeah
i don't know when i was in high school
it was really happening extreme home
makeover
yeah i'm in soft spots i love it do you
remember the stream makeover like the
like the makeover the surgery one the
surgery one we're saying hey you're so
busted but young just so lovely
but we're going to turn you acceptable
in the air into the pump like this
we're going to change your face
10. your face is repugnant
and that personality can land a man but
not that body girl
move that body
away
[ __ ] hey
another seven someone better rob me
they'll need y'all
i don't got sex [ __ ]
i just want to be pillaged once
yeah dude what is up this pizza man yeah
what the [ __ ]
man
have you given up
pizza just a myth at this point yeah
doesn't actually i ordered it like it
shows up god exists
should i call hanzo
what should i
five hours ago looking like it's still
tracking at 850 ford
oh my god you know hold up actually
let me check the door
because they usually might just leave it
they leave the pizza
this is my culture
yeah dude hopefully the uh somebody
showed up what time did you order it
at 8 54. so it's only been two hours
only
it's only been an hour and 40 minutes i
hope domino's watching right now this is
an exercise impatient do you want
pillows when you're using this easier
side yeah
you didn't like that suicide
no just just take something i need
something interesting move
going up to the guy with two points yeah
he's waiting wait i'm leaving
wait what just happened the others
he pillaged me and fell
all right it's your turn do you feel
pillaged uh does anybody want to trade
wheat for or
you want we or you're giving weight i'm
giving wheat oh good give me your hands
yeah
love you man love you too man yeah
that's how i love all you guys so much
yeah
okay
gonna take the next step in my evolution
as a player
whoa there we go
yeah yeah that's got more points here
hell yeah this is a personal record from
hannah
look at that
yeah dude yeah go for it
before i start my turn i would like to
relinquish knight
to have largest army and [ __ ] man and
move it hit yonder
who are you taken from that's a great
question
[ __ ] your eight points now dude
yeah i take from you oh yeah hans
i think he was never said no but okay
wow i got exactly what i needed
road this is a close game all things
considered
this is wild right now shit's going down
it feels so happy to have supplied sheep
too
you really kind of [ __ ] in terms of
building because you got to go all the
way there all the way out there i really
can't build anywhere make that longest
road evolving
[ __ ] me
oh my god any of these three words
all right
what's up there's that thanks
army yes you can
nine
i'm just gonna take a def card sheet and
move on
you gotta pay the truck we get into the
boys hole
gotta pay the truck
to get in
does that mean since my road connects
next to the wheat i can get some weight
or no
if it's touching it yeah
seven seven
uh
i don't know i can't pillage myself
i'm gonna go whoever this guy is
that's korean just shooting that in the
dark dude
it's all right man
no hardship
[Music]
jesus christ
all right
huh
uh
yeah
that's what you need over here
i uh
i'm gonna come over to honda's court
actually what what do you got
once you're acting like this is a new
thing
oh thank you
that was nice um
all right gotta pay the tool
[Music]
my friend said i should be patient can
you just bring it to me in three days
it's it's busy now could have eggs and
toast
sometimes just [ __ ] fire well play it
dude i'm honestly leaving not you out i
just
i'm honestly worried about splunk should
i call the cops
you guys want to [ __ ] dude i want a
case of i need to get some queso fresca
and put it on that [ __ ]
brassica yeah fresco and some eggs oh
dope dude what time do they close
midnight so i'm just gonna drive by make
sure everything's all right
yeah
that's where officer this is your friend
they were already shot up when i got
here
caleb's done right yeah i'm done
did anyone have any sheep or
all right definitely get some street
food wood yeah sure i'll take my wood
dude he's [ __ ] running away with this
[ __ ]
does anyone have
an ore
for a weed not for you [ __ ]
i don't have any work hans no what about
you good sir
dude i'm good i'm just stacking up on
like sheep
and like wheat and wood more wood than
you're getting all right
again
hey
oh i didn't hear that either
all right let me pick up another dev
card here
seven
[ __ ]
yeah we needed out of that deal
not really
oh my god
come on
i don't know
help
you oh man okay i don't know i think we
suck at this game yeah so it should be
going war with the elites dude like the
impoverished right wait
dude we're trying to reflect modern
society how dumb yeah like we're
well that's what we represent what does
this night mean
let's start robbing the pool where's the
nightmare you get to move the robber
dude you get to move it again do it
again we're going to go back to you
caleb and just
if you want yeah we're going to write it
oh you are i'm selling the top player
okay who cares
i got wheat
yeah if i was smoking that
[ __ ]
okay
five
oh let's go what i needed
well we like to [ __ ] see baby
god bless you
you're welcome
um
does anybody want to trade uh
some wheat uh do you guys need wheat
does anybody
would not or
uh what do i need there's a little wheat
shortage for a little bit there but it's
it's cleared up man
it's all good yeah i know
uh
i'm gonna die with wheat
are you dumb yeah go for it i guess
three all right let's go about time oh
sheesh
she
tell you what i built this settlement a
long time ago without this angle so
[Music]
chad
i'm good thanks oh what do you what do
you do that's [ __ ] up probably not her
for what you see is she
yeah for wood yeah i got you
nice today
all right you're good all right let's
see it
fine [ __ ] me
sheep
three
all right we're cruising on those threes
now
oh sh
who wants shape
what are you giving away for it wood
dude this camera angle is concerning it
looks like i'm balding bad dude you are
i don't think so no problem look look
how old it looks in the camera it looks
like it's it looks like it's three
quarters so we have my [ __ ] head dude
you just got like a
sharp peak right here it's not on the
other side
and trade in the you said four of these
i took some trt the other day i think
that might have been what did it nice
they're gonna do this through this one
put another little
ball like appendage somewhere ever do
that
you can pick victory flip victory points
up as you pick them up or you gotta wait
a turn
you're gonna play it whenever you want
well you have to usually wait a turn
like if you if i draw one can i just be
like yeah
can you oh i usually wait a turn
everybody plays a little bit different
why are you asking
i don't know hans maybe i'm
doing 578
does anybody want to trade does anybody
need sheep or yeah i do you do uh do you
have um water
uh actually do you have uh brick uh no
no no
wood do you have john i'm sorry wood was
flying around earlier yeah what was in
that wood
look what happened to it he put a robber
on it oh
yeah
um
[ __ ]
does anybody have wood sure no
do you know every time you talk i get
wood
that's super nice you done yeah
all right we'll move on do i need to
roll again you won yeah
oh i have two victory oh oh [ __ ]
damn you only you won with two cities
that's all you know
i was getting close i had nine and i was
hoping that you're about to make a city
and win i saw you dude you're about to
win i was well i had i couldn't build it
on anything i was hoping i would pick up
a little bit yeah were you trying to
build a city and then you would have won
you have two these aren't victory points
oh no i got a well i got eight on there
dude i got i had a victory point at
night
exactly i was waiting on that [ __ ]
thing
well play boys good times that was fun
yeah you came from behind for sure
i don't remember you talking [ __ ] before
saying i have any points
because what yeah you have as many
points on the board as caleb does
yeah i know right except i don't know
weird too i was like he was wondering a
game within the game yeah
you're getting going first of all matrix
yeah
you're going for homecoming king and
queen and
star quarterback even
even with the ai players it's still very
good
dude they're npcs
you play skyrim back in the day
i [ __ ] love skyrim i lost i lost the
whole summer to skyrim dude
what is the only one
of the game just looking over here
slay dragons and get rich dude
what was your console uh
i got a pc specifically with the game
because the macho man randy savage
dragon mod
yes it is beautiful it's you you fight a
macho man randy savage dragon instead of
the dragon shout out it's just him going
yeah
yeah oh yeah
and it's just [ __ ] amazing
what a great addition are you from
downtown yeah i might hop in with you if
that's cool yeah yeah let's roll look
this over here uh i did take a new rear
i was at the creek i figured i'd just
come down [ __ ] up somebody's house
i appreciate you having me it's a good
time yeah thanks for coming of course
yeah i just picked my own live tv
thanks for tuning in yeah yes thanks
guys yeah come